>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Welcome,
welcome to the Library of Congress.
We're delighted to see you all.
We're delighted to see all the
great support for the City of Tyre
and for its collections
and for everything.
We're going to do a brief
set of introductions.
And the first person I would like
to introduce is Ambassador Killian
who is the President of the
American Committee for Tyre.
So, Ambassador Killian, will
you please come to the stage.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Ambassador David
Killian: Thank you very much.
And I just want to offer my
deep appreciation to the Library
of Congress for hosting
this incredible event.
I heard that I was overseas,
but I just got back and I heard
that today's seminars were
incredibly successful.
And I think this is a great
opportunity to introduce a lot
of people to a project that Maha
Chalabi has been championing
for over 40 years.
A great, great project
aimed at preserving one
of our most important civilizational
treasures, the City of Tyre.
And so without further ado, I
want to introduce Maha Chalabi,
the founder of the, all
of the Tyre foundations.
The original foundation and
the American foundation.
Maha Chalabi.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Maha El-Khalil Chalabi:
Good evening, everybody.
And thank a lot to be with us today.
The whole day was great
because you were there.
I thank the Ambassador of Lebanon,
I thank everybody here, ambassadors.
[ Applause ]
The tired day is coming to an end.
Needless to say, it's a
highly emotional moment, Tyre,
the Queen of the Seas, was
present throughout the day as Queen
of History, culture, and notably
Queen of Peaceful Globalization.
The speakers, prominent experts from
the U.S., Belgium, France, Greece,
Tunisia, and Lebanon have
brilliantly shed a new light
on the unknown history of Tyre.
Allow me to present
to each and every one
of them my most sincere appreciation
for their valuable contributions.
The organization of Tyre day within
the cultural shrine of the Library
of Congress wouldn't have been
possible without the efforts
of the Librarian Mr. James
Billington and Mrs. Mary-Jane Deeb
as well as the tireless
determination of the U.S. Committee
for Tyre shared by his
Excellency Ambassador David Killian
and the Honorable Chairs
Mr. [inaudible].
And I have to say a special thanks
to my daughter Hareem Chalabi.
[ Applause ]
For all members of our committee,
a very, very special thanks also.
The presence here of
many personalities
from the various background
is a living testimony
of the great support to all
those who are working tirelessly
to promote a prestigious
civilization definition,
civilization.
Impressively presented
by the City of Tyre.
My warmest thanks goes
especially to senators, ministers,
ambassadors representing different
country worldwide present tonight
with us.
Many thanks extended to
Robert Newlen, Chief of Staff
to the Library and as a
token, please, Mr. Newlen,
Mr. Robert Newlen, Chief
of Staff of the Library.
As a token of our appreciation
to the Library of Congress,
the International Association
to Save Tyre
and the committee [inaudible].
And the committee for
Tyre would like to offer,
Wendell [phonetic] books would like
to offer two special books on behalf
of our research institute
of [inaudible]
and [inaudible] civilization
to be for the collection.
To be given to the
collection of the Asian
and African Middle East Division.
So this will be handled through
Mary-Jane Deeb with all the thanks.
The first one, Assyrian
Discoveries written
by George Smith and
published in 1975.
And the second one named.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
Written by [inaudible]
and published in 1766.
These books are both first
editions and are incredibly rare.
Because of their age
and global importance,
I am personally convinced that there
is no better place than the Library
of Congress to keep these
two historical pieces
of literature in pristine condition.
[ Applause ]
>> Maha El-Khalil Chalabi:
Thank you, really.
I thank you for everything.
>> Thank you.
>> Maha El-Khalil Chalabi:
You're welcome.
I will, I would like now
to call on Mr. Clay Pell,
the grandson of Senator
Claiborne Pell.
[ Applause ]
Please, hello.
>> Clay Pell: Hello.
>> Maha El-Khalil Chalabi:
It gives me great pleasure
to [inaudible] present this special
award to the late legendary senator
from Rhode Island, Claiborne Pell.
As most of you know, Senator Pell
was a man of incomparable dedication
to the betterment of human kind.
For 36 years, he was
one of Rhode Island's
and this nation most
beloved politician.
Accepting the award on behalf
of the Pell family is Clay Pell.
The senator's namesake and grandson.
I will tell you more about this
remarkable young man a little later.
Indeed, Senator Pell's
legacy is a rich one.
He is most well known in the
United States as the person
who conceived the Pell Grant Program
which is probably his
most lasting achievement.
This program made the dream of
a higher education a reality
for millions of American students.
Senator Pell, his deep and abandoned
interest in antiquities took him
to many places including
our beloved Tyre in 1982.
And he was a [inaudible]
chairman of the American Committee
to Save Tyre for more than 25 year.
During confirmation
hearing for U.S. ambassador
about to take their post Lebanon,
he became common knowledge
in the state department
to prepare nominees
to answer Senator Pell's
question about Tyre.
He facilitates the Tyre Committee's
interaction with governments
and [inaudible] and
private organization
that could help preserve Tyre.
So.
[ Backgrounds Sounds ]
Please accept this award on
behalf of Claiborne Pell.
>> Clay Pell: Thank you very much.
>> Maha El-Khalil Chalabi:
And the family.
Thank you.
>> Clay Pell: Thank you.
>> Maha El-Khalil Chalabi: Yes, yes.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Clay Pell: Thank you so, so much.
>> Maha El-Khalil Chalabi:
You're welcome, thank you.
[ Background Sounds ]
And it was Senator Pell who
introduced me to Esther Coopersmith,
our second honoree this evening.
I would like to acknowledge
the commitment
of the honorable Esther
Coopersmith for Tyre.
Having just mentioned
Senator Claiborne Pell,
I recall when he first urged me
to engage Esther as a key person
to the potential success of the
American Committee for Tyre.
He couldn't have been more right.
Esther was been a pioneer for
our cause over the past 35 years.
Her contribution allowed
us to forge connections
that made the American Committee
for Tyre what it is today.
So it's her son, Jonathan
Coopersmith, who is with us today.
[ Applause ]
And will receive.
Please accept this award for Esther.
>> Jonathan Coopersmith: Thank you.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Maha El-Khalil Chalabi: I
conclude, I conclude by announcing
that you have today with us,
he came from far to attend.
You'll remember I recall on our
lottery 100 euro for a Picasso.
And the gentleman who won,
this speaker saw and he was,
he is American gentleman
Jeffrey Gonano [phonetic].
So he is with us today.
And through this lottery,
we were able to conclude
and to start our projects,
many projects for Tyre.
So thank you.
>> Jeffrey Gonano: Thank you.
>> Maha El-Khalil Chalabi:
Thank you.
Now, I have to tell you everybody
thanks and we are going to give the,
who is going to talk now?
No? No? To invite you.
Yes, Madame Anne Marie Lizin,
Senator Anne Marie Lizin.
An already President of the Senate
of Belgium, she will conclude
with few words about our
fabulous day, Tyre day.
Please, Anne Marie, can you.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Anne Marie Lizin: So you haven't,
first I have to ask your indulgence
for my English and for my voice.
We are completely direct with
all the work we do today.
I have the great honor to conclude
this event with congratulation
for all of you for your
commitment to history
to Tyre and to the vengeance.
When European or Lebanese
citizens are coming
to U.S., it seems so far away.
Seven hour flight, nine
hour flight sometimes.
And we may well imagine the
[inaudible] ready to do the same.
This trip to Atlantic
from [inaudible]
or from any of the [inaudible].
The development, the
[inaudible] ability, the culture,
where are the time moving from
Mediterranean to Europe and trying
to reach the American territory.
Of course, the two big
wars in Europe have step
by step created the reverse trend.
For us, technical evolutions have
made relation easier, quicker,
and finally a more dangerous world.
The room where we are
here, all this building
of the library is a testimony of all
what happened if there's a cultural,
historical, and political changes.
It is de facto the biggest archives
of the change in the last centuries.
We are, Mrs. Deeb especially, we
are proud of being your guests.
Of course, none of us will forget
that we are also sharing
contradictions of the actual world.
This week, for example, we
still do not know what happens
to the [inaudible] of
the city of [inaudible].
Our commitment for Tyre makes
those cultures at the risk
of intellectual backlash.
Of [inaudible], disintegration
of all traces of civilization.
But we must also strongly, and
I want to conclude with that.
We want strongly remember
that if we are all here,
it's due to one person.
And we all know her.
She is Maha El-Khalil Chalabi.
She is the symbol of the Tyre.
But she is a symbol of a courageous
woman in a difficult time.
She is able to move mountains.
Coming from a mostly [inaudible],
able to fight, and able to succeed
in the most dangerous surrounding.
And especially refusing
to let the world forget
about Tyre and the vengeance.
Muslim world has always
generated strong woman.
[ Inaudible ]
Was one of them.
But Maha El-Khalil Chalabi
is for Tyre a modern model
of what we want for woman.
And I want you as a conclusion to
really make a standing ovation,
we all stand for Maha [applause].
She has the way in
her fantastic way,
and we are on our way
to go further with her.
Thank you.
>> Maha El-Khalil Chalabi:
I'm very thank you,
I am very confused.
Many thanks.
And now, perhaps, we should invite
you to the opening of the display
of the books in the
Library of Congress
about Tyre on the second floor.
And to have the dinner with us also.
Thank you for everything.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.